meet Marcin and tingoora two adorable  dingers no these aren't pet dogs they're  actually wild animals dingers are  australia's wild dog considered a  cultural icon but due to interbreeding  pure dingers have become harder to spot  hence both Morrison and tangora's  similar appearance to domestic dogs  dingers are thought to have been  introduced to Australia three to four  thousand years ago they are Australia's  largest terrestrial predator dingoes  hunt everything from rodents and birds  to larger prey like kangaroos they are a  big part of Aboriginal Australian  culture yet a seen as pests by livestock  farmers due to perceived attacks on  animals hunting for their skin and  interbreeding has left their population  vulnerable this is the dingo  you